enfin avec nous Bruno fucks bienvenue à
vous vous êtes un ancien journaliste
aujourd'hui député MoDem du Haut-Rhin
bon connaisseur de l'Afrique vous aussi
et depuis peu secrétaire général de
l'Assemblée parlementaire de la
Francophonie vous venez de lancer une
mission parlementaire à propos je cite
de la stratégie française en Afrique la
France est devenue une puissance comme
une autre en Afrique qu'elle suscite
même de l'hostilité dans certains pays
l'objectif de cette mission et de mettre
en lumière les raisons pour lesquelles
la France a perdu une part de son
influence en Afrique dites-vous à nos
confrères des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace c'était le 19 mars dernier à
quelle date votre mission va-t-elle
rendre ses conclusions lorsque un
monsieur qui est très vaste il faut
consulter beaucoup de d'experts dans
beaucoup de domaines donc on pense que
d'ici le mois de septembre on aura fait
un travail suffisant pour d'une part
analyser un certain nombre d'éléments
mais surtout faire des propositions pour
voir comment effectivement on peut
restaurer une posture et donc une
influence qui correspond plus à la
situation de la France et à ses
ambitions rendez-vous donc en septembre
prochain pour les conclusions de cette
mission que vous êtes en train de lancer
ici à l'Assemblée nationale on va même
constat aujourd'hui vous parler d'un
échec quand on voit la fin de la mission
barkhane oui c'est un échec je crois
personne ne peut dire l'inverse quand on
regarde la réalisation de ce que
barkhane a fait pendant 9 ans il y a
quand même beaucoup il y a eu des succès
c'est une mission qui a servi à
combattre l'avancée et une grande partie
justement des tentatives d'attaque
terroristes on voit un officier
militaire dans ce documentaire qui dit
il y a eu deux portes de sortie il y a
un moment dans cette histoire la
première c'était la fin de l'opération
Serval où les militaires français aurait
pu se retirer considérant que mission
avait été accomplie et la deuxième porte
de sortie ça aurait pu être l'élection
d'un nouveau président
et le maintien de la démocratie bien
entendu et l'élection d'un président
qu'on a vu évidemment dans ce
documentaire à la tête du pays on a pris
une ni l'une ni l'autre est-ce que ça a
été euh l'erreur fondamentale sur le
plan militaire parce que c'est l'analyse
déjà de l'objectif de barkhane le
général Castres qui est dans ce
reportage piloté l'opération Serval et
il a souhaité que barkhane change de nom
et soit pas à la suite de Serval pense
déjà que pour sanctuariser la réussite
de Serval il a voulu donner un autre nom
à barkhane pensant déjà que d'embarcades
il y avait les germes d'une fin annoncée
la difficulté c'est qu'il y avait pas de
stratégie d'embarca on voit bien et vous
l'avez bien dit que l'objectif c'est de
combattre le terrorisme et d'accompagner
les états or en cama accompagne pas les
états avec
3000 4000 5000 hommes uniquement des
militaires qui eux sont en opération
militaire donc un je pense qu'il a
manqué si on pouvait faire l'analyse
évidemment stratégiques et de
d'accompagner d'accompagnement de l'état
des services publics donc en plus de
l'armée il aurait fallu certainement
accompagner les États à restaurer leur
service public et assurer sécuriser les
zones que l'on avait permis de
reconquérir parce qu'il y a eu des
reconquêtes voilà et après sur les
détails il y a eu d'autres éléments pour
analyser
l'échec mais principalement l'opération
c'est pas un échec militaire il est
plutôt c'est plutôt un échec stratégique
et le Mali comme d'ailleurs le Burkina
Faso finalement
dénonce l'abandon l'État français pour
justifier ce renversement d'alliance oui
alors il y a plusieurs éléments le
premier c'est qu'on simplifie le débat
en disant Wagner ou la France la Russie
la France il y a quand même sur place
l'Union européenne il y a 14000 soldats
ou policiers de la minusma donc le débat
il se limite pas non plus à cette
médiatiquement qu'on limite à ce
mouvement ce sont les forces de l'ONU de
le l'ONU et il y a quand même 4 fois
plus de soldats de l'ONU que de force
française au plus haut de la force
barkhane donc la situation est pas aussi
simple que ça sur Wagner donc vous avez
dit mille soldats sont les chiffres qui
circulent maintenant de toute façon
c'est très opaque comme vous venez de le
dire mais on voit bien que que ces
soldats sont plutôt là pour essayer de
sécuriser la jungle et le pouvoir en
place que pour faire des opérations
militaires de grande envergure peut-être
dans deux ou trois zones précises mais
peuvent pas aller beaucoup plus loin et
on voit que la question qui celle qu'on
a évoquée tout à l'heure de la
résolution politique n'est pas plus
abordée maintenant qu'elle ne l'était
avant la résolution on peut pas dire en
Ukraine que la résolution va être
politique à la fin et pas imaginer que
celle la raison sera politique et je
pense qu'une des erreurs si on veut
revenir ces heures de conception que la
France a pu commettre c'est que on a
pensé que la résolution de
le conflit pouvait être militaire et à
un moment quand Jean-Yves Le Drian dit
on ne peut pas négocier avec les
terroristes il a raison d'un point de
vue conceptuel pense que la résolution
du Mali on le verra ne peut être que
politique et donc peut être avancé que
lorsque l'on a commencé à discuter pas
avec les groupes djihadistes les deux
groupes acmis et l'État islamique mais
avec une grande partie de la terreur
locale ou de l'insécurité locale qui
sont provoquées par des questions
purement ethniques et non pas par des
questions idéologiques ou islamiques
alors dans les résultats sont pour elles
sont très très limités dans la
négociation au Niger c'est très très
limité comme résultat mais ça veut dire
que en parallèle de la force militaire
il faut avoir une approche stratégique
et politique
effectivement c'est peut-être un des
éléments positifs entre guillemets de la
fin de barcades c'est la France c'est
réinterroger sur la doctrine à mettre en
place et j'étais obligé moi il y a trois
semaines il y a au Niger des soldats
français ils sont sous commandement
nigériens et ils sont sous stratégie
Niger cela nigériens qui décide de la
stratégie et qui décide des opérations
et donc quand ils ont des Français ils
appellent les Français il y a une
échange d'information ce qui était ni le
cas au Mali niika au Burkina il y a des
comités de pilotage commun et on est un
peu comme des sous-traitants là-bas
regardez ce mot pour simplifier ça c'est
l'immunité évoquée par le chef de l'État
mais ça veut dire que ça change
radicalement complètement et l'armée
nigérienne qui s'est dotée depuis le
président Bazoom qui a multiplié par 3
ces effectifs et qui va encore par deux
c'est à dire qu'en disant ils vont être
multipliés par 6 et bien là on voit
qu'il y a une capacité d'intervention
beaucoup plus forte des Nigériens le
meilleur reprises en compte des
capacités stratégiques et derrière les
Français qui viennent en renfort et donc
ça c'est très différent de ce qui s'est
fait et au Mali et au Burkina et le plus
difficile pour les Français ça va être
effectivement de se mettre dans une
posture dans une attitude au service de
ce qui n'est pas depuis depuis la
colonisation qui n'est pas l'attitude
principale des français en Afrique et ça
ça peut être un changement de 30
secondes votre point de vue je pense que
les contre la France oui comme quantité
coloniale et post-coloniale mais pas
avec les Français moi je continue à
parler avec les mêmes personnes au Mali
qu'avant il y a pas de différence donc
moi ce qu'on dit en Afrique on me dit on
veut on veut la France mais on la veut
autrement et c'est autrement qu'il faut
définir il faut du froid du temps pour
cela le principal souci à mon avis c'est
qu'on n'a pas les acteurs on n'a pas les
chefs d'entreprise on n'a pas les
mouvements associatifs qui connaissent
l'Afrique et qui vont investir l'Afrique
dans leur champ le problème
principal c'est celui-ci c'est que on
manque et de connaissance fine du
terrain et d'acteurs qui vont aller
s'investir là-bas
on a des millions de binationaux qui ne
demandent qu'à jouer la relation France
Afrique et en ne favorise pas
suffisamment les stratégies vers les
binationaux qui sont populations tout à
fait apte et qui ont envie de jouer leur
deux pays d'origine et on verra ainsi
cet autrement c'est ce fameux solutions
que vous évoquez figurant dans
évidemment dans le rapport de votre
mission parlementaire que vous êtes en
train de mettre en place et vous nous
avez annoncé que les conclusions de
cette mission devrait être connue si
tout va bien en septembre prochain